There is a campaign.
Jane, right now that is looking to revise
history.
OK.
It's a very aggressive campaign, in fact,
that is armed with cease and desist letters.
And this is a campaign being fought by Donald
Trump's campaign for reelection, panicked
about Corona virus as they should be.
They are now going around trying to scrub
and remove evidence that Trump was using the
term hoax when discussing Corona virus just
weeks ago.
Feels like months ago or even longer that
we thought maybe this corona virus thing won't
be a big deal.
But Donald Trump was calling it a hoax.
Just a few weeks ago, and the first move that
the Trump campaign made 10 days ago was to
start saying not and no, he he never met the
virus was a hoax.
What he meant was that Democrats are doing
a hoax by distorting this or by trying to
use it against Trump or whatever.
At one point, Trump said that Democrats were
victims of the hoax.
Sometimes they perpetrated it like it was
completely incoherent.
Every time Trump would say something different.
But the idea was that Donald Trump believed
Corona virus would be no big deal.
That's the whole point of what he was saying
that has been proven very, very wrong.
Whichever of these conflicting and contradictory
versions of what Trump meant by hoax, you
believe it's bad for Trump no matter what.
For this video to be floating around, there's
no question about it.
So now they're taking it up a notch.
The Trump campaign is trying to get these
videos removed from the Internet.
Any video in which he uses the word hoax in
connection with coronavirus is bad for Donald
Trump.
Now, there is a PAC which has been issued
a cease and desist letter.
The PAC has called Priorities USA Action.
It's a PAC that supports Democratic candidates.
And they have received a cease and desist
letter from the Trump campaign, which says
you are airing patently false, misleading
and deceptive advertisements made by a political
action committee.
They are sending the cease and desist to TV
stations, telling them stop airing this ad
from this PAC.
Let's look at the ad so that we all understand
what we're talking about.
It is pretty solid as far as an ad goes.
You're going to hear Trump downplaying the
virus while on screen.
If you're watching the case, numbers are rising.
Imagine that if you're just listening today
while you hear this audio.
There is a growing number of cases on screen.
The Corona virus, is that new hoax?
We have it totally under control.
One person coming in from China one day.
It's like a miracle.
It will disappear when you have 15 people.
And within a couple of days, it's going to
be down to close to zero.
We really think we've done a great job in
keeping it down to a minimum.
I like this.
I really get it.
It was surprising.
I understand.
No, I don't take responsibility at all.
Priorities USA Action is responsible for the
content of this app.
So this is their new hoax is what they're
taking issue with.
There's that.
They're saying that is out of context.
It makes it sound like Trump was saying the
virus is a hoax when that's not what he meant.
He meant that Democrats are using this to
attack him just like they did with the witch
hunt hoax, just like they did with the impeachment
hoax.
That's the argument that they're trying to
make now.
What's really going on is that they're panicking.
They're panicking over the reality that there
is nothing hoax like about Corona virus.
There never was anything hoax likes hoax,
like about the seriousness with which Democrats
were dealing with Corona virus from the beginning.
They want to pretend that it's about this
one ad being deceptive or out of context.
But even if you win that argument and grant
that, OK, Trump didn't say the virus is a
hoax.
In this particular video, even if you grant
that Trump has been downplaying the entire
thing from the beginning, and as a result,
we have a higher death toll.
We have half of our states doing nothing in
terms of physical distancing and shutting
things down.
Everything Trump has been saying all along
has been proven to be false.
Trump brought, you know, H1N1 as something
that Obama bungled and said this isn't going
to be as bad.
Well, we now have a worldwide death toll in
the 20000 soon going to the 30 thousands.
And Trump and his campaign are concerned about
getting videos off of the Internet and off
of TV rather than actually dealing with the
problem.
This entire game of, you know, what he meant
to say.
It's literally revisionist history.
And of course, at any time they could pull
out the entire.
It was just a joke thing.
They've done it before.
It seems as though they realized that in this
case saying it was a joke when Trump said
it would look very bad given the numbers.
If you haven't been following the numbers,
we just went.
It took us months to get to 100000 global
cases.
We just went from 400000 global cases to.
Five hundred thousand global cases in two
days.
And Donald Trump is focused on getting videos
pulled from TV and the Internet, where he
uses the word hoax in the context of the current
coronavirus.
The priorities have been wrong from day one.
They continue to be wrong.
And this is all posturing from November.
That's what this is fundamentally coming down
to decisions about.
Do we open up the economy or don't we?
It's all about reelection.
The Easter thing.
There may even be influence from Christians
there wanting things open back up by Easter.
There's an interesting article about that
that I read yesterday.
Ken fout should be allowed to say stuff.
Or is it damaging because he contradicts Donald
Trump?
Everything is optics.
Everything is stock markets, the economy,
money, blah, blah, blah.
When the reality is, if the death toll gets
to where some of the worst estimates suggest
it could, if we don't do anything, that is
going to be far worse for the country than
dealing with a stock market decline and high
unemployment rates for a few months, that
we really should be buckling down completely.
If you disagree with my take, but if there's
people in the audience who think we shouldn't
actually be closing down more now and just
grinning and bearing it and waiting if you
have a different approach.
What I want to hear from you is give me a
metric, give me data that suggests we've turned
the corner and we should be looking at opening
things back up.
I'm searching for it.
I've been looking I can't find any such data.
I'm on Twitter
at
David Pakman.
If you want to let me know.